werde einen hut auf eine mitsprache
work-life-balance wichtiger dachstuhl
oder
sind sie es leid ich war
[Musik]
heute ist fleisch und bossard mit dem
ihf und wir darüber diskutieren sowie
die alltagssorgen wird gott zum thema
macht arbeit einfach glücklich oder
granit ära ich mache den job ich
glücklich jetzt im moment so ja also das
ist schönste wenn wir die schöne
gespräche führen mit kluge menschen das
machen wir ja der sternstunden
nein das ist
bezahlt ist entfalten kann
aber es ging rheinsbergs job dass kein
stück genauso wenig mails siebziger und
so vida libre man genau so wenig sieht
dafür den vorbereitet wurden also von
höheren niveau klagt er ausstrahlt ist
und wo man nicht glücklich macht würde
ich sagen ich weiß nicht so recht was
ist eigentlich durch ethik also wenn wir
jetzt noch mich mega glücklich ich denke
arbeit und ich glaube das stimmt ja
nicht sondern verhaltens verordnet und
glück dass ich im land vorgeschrieben
wieder neu bestimmt wurde und ästhetik
ist unter www corbis macht durch
unglücklich das beste draus mache ich
nicht schafft also nicht wirklich freie
mensch technik schafft geschaffen kann
nutzt
aber jetzt also meine klappe totalen
traxinger schafft oder das ist viele
definierte total überarbeitet gefragt
und was machst du es ist sehr nett
idealer wie es schafft also ideal ist
die grenze zwischen arbeit und freizeit
fließend und du schaffst jeder für sich
selber und die maschen und sowie das ist
neue ideal und ich glaube wenn man die
geschichte wirkt was der noch der antike
ich war nicht die frage einer möglichen
sie sind der hund religions- christentum
und sperrte den protestantismus über das
um regierungszeit
ora et labora und der luther scheißegal
arbeit als gottesdienst als sicher bis
sehr edles und es wird aufgewertet und
letztlich die religiöse dimension oder
arbeit in eine störung zum christentum
und selbst im kapitalismus drinnen ist
der max weber mit seiner these oder der
geist von kapitalismus wurde
protestantische ethik der arbeitsmoral
drinnen ist und das spürt schon wieder
im live ticker ideal dass da irgendwie
mit selbstentfaltung fast zu erlösen
oder genauer
kissen sogar ideologie verarbeitung ganz
extrem darum mitgliederschaft machen
wonach das geht so eine
abschlussrechnung steve jobs r 2000
feucht ist auf youtube viral gab es was
genau dass gordon scheinlich das findet
wieder schafft auch gern machen denn wir
folglich sie und mich stört es auch als
ein wenig über das wir spielen alle eine
charity world cheese um die er über
identifikation mit der lohnarbeit
wirklich kritisch gesehen und anderen
ist was ich gilt natürlich nur für ganze
auch die minderheit einem ganzfeld
schätzungen nicht willst du mit
liegenschaft natürlich hast du wieder
schafft lerneffekt person bedient das
programm verwenden becker schafft aber
für völlig oder analytisch an diesem tag
einfach wichtig dass ihre job machen zu
einem lohn
und es geht darum sich zurück ja das ist
schon der punkt dass ich meine es gibt
ja andreas ragwitz soziologen sieht
diagnostik etwas etwas passiert ist
horizont ist ein spalt ich von der
mittelschicht also es geht jetzt
eigentlich eine dreiklassengesellschaft
sein obere mittelschicht sind
akademikerinnen und so weiter dann würde
mir zu erzählen aber sie könnte der
luxus hat sich der verwalter ihren job
und die gibt es ein altes jobs magerte
jetzt langsam muss stärker sind und war
schlechter bezahlt sind und eine
schlechtere anna könig kennt und da geht
es dann zurück so genannte service class
als die prekäre krass wo also das haar
einigung transport sicher die ganze
paketboten jetzt im lokal und so weiter
aber
reinigungskraft im internet das die
ganze klingt also dann irgendwie die
videos und psychologe und mit denen
komplettieren löschen genau an die sache
meint einfach gemacht wer damit mir doch
irgendwie der komfortzone aber das muss
man sicher sagen
sie muss nicht glücklich machen sondern
in zschopau und sehe ich eigentlich ein
stück weit glücklich was man ganz sicher
weiß ich arbeitslosigkeit noch ganz
sicher tief unglücklich auf eine glut
folgt arbeitslose menschen sagt sie
halte mich lieber wieder ein job will
unsere gesellschaft in zschopau
natürlich alle mit sozialen training
hier gottes sind im april wenn man sich
fragt am abbruch es macht stehende um
den erwarteten arbeit ein arbeits
antwort und nicht einseitig singen im
chor oder fahren vielleicht aber nur
unsere bottle machen wir das so also
glaube einfach nicht sicher ist
ebenfalls ich selbst an meine älteren ob
intel die sich vorstellen ist erwarte
ich dass man für den job macht
ja ist die offizielle vielleicht genau
aber ich meine hier arbeitslos ja aber
ich interessant ist also faktisch ist
das wenn man arbeitslos ist denn
tendenziell ein unglücklicher ist das
macht mit struktur damit allerdings tue
ich habe selber erlebt
zum glück habe es uns wichtig sich eine
frau 67 irgendwie ans netz nehmen kann
soziale und hat gemerkt wir haben das
aber passiert und wie man auf dauer
bleibt für die struktur der arkaden
genau und
bis heute machen wo du noch als
production zeigt das ist dass wir teil
von mir das bfs ist ein
selbstverwirklichung services beim
hegering arbeit extrem aufgewertet
höherer stellenwert dieser form in
österreich von mir selber es ist in form
von selbsterkenntnis letztlich
natürlich natürlich die
künstlerinnen und künstler ausgerichtete
wurden sich abmüht arbeitet sich selber
an und biss so zeigt wie ein geburt
leistet dafür bis ein anderer als
spielgerät aber klar wenn du natürlich
irgendwie immer spitze putzen oder
cluster schaffen so das repetitive das
ist dann eher entfremdung nicht inhärent
fertigt da gibt es interessante
geschichten steinmetzer der erste steine
zeitig der 2 seit ich habe stets und
ganz verdient sich bei familie zu
ernähren und
dritter der kathedrale wenn man ihn
fragt wer ist die glückliche dritte wenn
die vorstellung dass man sich machen
kürzungen der größere ganze entweder zum
in der session wirklichen ordern ich bin
teil von resident evil ist enorm wichtig
dass du das gefühl hast du gehörst dazu
und du du schaffst woche braucht wasser
oder wo eben wie in ein remis die idee
realisiert aber interessantes aus dem
abitur eigentlich zeigen dass europas
wertschätzend und das ist bedauernswert
findet unserer gesellschaft
gesellschafters kaltluft das wird sich
porsche nach angesagt als
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen hat geht
es einfach nicht recht und vor anderen
zu sagen mir im zug für die
automatisierung von der digitalisierung
wenn all die repetitive jobs wegen einer
schwarzfahrt künstliche intelligenz wenn
das roboter und zu künstliche system
bessere werden wir einen punkt ohne um
das bedingungslose grundeinkommen
studien und literatur und viel vor dem
pc stumme aber ich glaube
chance von der arbeit ich habe dir also
wenn man jetzt wenn man sagt gemacht
aber das glück vielleicht kann man sagen
die macht nicht glücklich privilegiert
die oberschicht machte aber soll sie
glücklich machen und die ping die schon
wenn man die zukunft wirkt was am ried
für das modell ich finde ja dass sonst
eigentlich also eigentlich sehr bedingt
dass sie unbedingt den klinsmann
nicht unglücklich machen und war über
den punkt es geht massiv ausbeuterische
arbeitsverhältnisse
gesundheitsschädigung die arbeit es geht
unwürdige arbeit und das alles als
besichtigen wer schon als großes ziel
also man sagen hat in erster linie nicht
unglücklich machen mal anständige
arbeitsverhältnis anständige löhne für
alle und nicht nur darüber reden sie
glücklich machen und ich glaube dass man
da wird spitzen und will unique user von
vornherein sie dann nicht 100 prozent
schaffen sie haben andere interessen im
nahen also wieder von anfang an
beschrieb es fällt mir auf dass
es gibt kritik oder liebhaber an die
sonntagnacht als gesellschafter bereit
sind wirklich voll gut sitzt
ja und wir haben damit zu widersprechen
kollegin was ganz anderes verhältnis zu
ihren job bezahlt dafür dass
eigentlichen arbeit und ihre selbst
fertig findet im wandel statt vielleicht
ist es
gar nicht so falsch
also letztlich extreme job ein roller
also hessen funktion du bisch nid dich
selber nummer immer und die das
schüttere oder die das liege im job
klappt oder findest du das mögen wir die
abgrenzung schafft das menschenmeer
später erinnert das ist nur eine davon
von japan ich bin anders teil von mir
ist da drin aber es ist nicht ganz
sauber und das ganze dorf und ich finde
dass ein wichtiger gedanke heutige zb
schafft die stadt will sander ist
nämlich genau so stark identifiziert
stehen auch wieder gefordert du
schaffst es aber ich würde mir denn am
besten schon heute mit dass man den
millionen ab mitte november gesagt wird
und was machst du eigentlich lieber doch
seit gartner gartner ja wie glücklich
macht dich dem spann coffrini kommentar
unter ihr gespannt
und wenn du jemand erfahren über
markt.de durch das sprechen mit dem
philosophen reihen jacke und um arbeit
ist natürlich auch gegangen im gespräch
mit dem soziologe andreas rettig wenn du
nicht verpassen vergleich und bussard
auch die wir noch blocken danke